[Musique]
bonjour à tous le grand débat national
en bourgogne au coeur de cette édition
spéciale sur france 3 bourgogne france
bleu bourgogne et france bleu auxerre le
service public porte ce débat à la radio
et à la télévision aujourd'hui pour
mieux comprendre ce qui se dit sur notre
territoire et entendre la parole des
citoyens qui participent ou pas
d'ailleurs parce que ça arrive aussi à
cette initiative lancée par le président
de la république inégalités
territoriales fractures sociales à venir
des services publics décentralisation
démocratie locale
on en débat avec nos invités thomas nous
gagnons aujourd'hui oui notre premier
invité c'est thierry falconnet bonjour
thierry falconnet jouent alors vous êtes
le maire socialiste de chenôve dans
l'agglomération dijonnaise
vous avez organisé quatre grands débats
déjà ça ne veut pas dire que vous
cautionnez forcément ce qui se dit la
façon dont c'est fait expliquez-nous
justement votre positionnement par
rapport à ces en débat la position de la
majorité municipale a chaussé nous
sommes organisateurs critique de ce
débat national
nous avons choisi une forme de quatre
réunions déconcentré donc dans quatre
lieux différents de la commune pour
permettre à l'ensemble des habitants de
d'y participer en proximité et nous
avons écrit à monsieur le préfet en lui
exprimant la position donc delà de la
ville la position de la majorité
municipale à savoir nous
nous saisissons l'occasion qui est
offerte aux citoyens de s'exprimer
donc nous jouons le jeu du grand débat
national mais nous émettons des
critiques d'abord sur le fait que l'état
nous demande d'organiser un débat sans
nécessairement s'occuper des conditions
matérielles par exemple mise à
disposition de locaux de personnels
municipaux les moyens de transmission de
la parole citoyenne à l'état et puis
ensuite sur le fond c'est-à-dire ce
grand débat très bien il a lieu partout
en france mais demain qu'en sera-t-il y
aura-t-il des réponses concrètes
on va en parler dans l'émission
évidemment absolument vingt deuxième
invité c'est vincent chauvet bonjour
vincent chauvet nos jours alors vous
êtes le maire modem d'autun vous
appartenez à la majorité présidentielle
vous vous allez organiser un grand débat
ce sera mi février le président de la
république venu cette semaine à autun il
là il s'est entretenu avec les jeunes
jeunesse qui était un petit peu on pas
dire l'oublier des grands départs en
fait on sent que les gens ont du mal à
se mobiliser autour de ce camp débat
absolument et le président de la
république a rencontré mille jeunes qui
lui ont posé toutes leurs questions
pendant plusieurs heures et on pouvait
se demander justement comment aller
s'inscrire cette jeunesse dans le grand
débat
on les a pas forcément trop vu remplir
les caisses doléances n'ont pas
forcément trop vus manifester on pouvait
se dire qu'ils étaient plus sur une
mobilisation numérique voir sur pas de
mobilisation du tout parce que ils ont
aussi leurs activités leurs
préoccupations et finalement ils ont
répondu présent avec un très haut niveau
de qualité d'écouté aussi de
questionnements c'était tout à fait
intéressant et nous mêmes nous allons
organiser et c'était prévu déjà avant le
16 février à 14 heures à la salle de
l'hexagone à autun un grand débat ouvert
à l'ensemble des maires du territoire
moi je suis un maire évangélisateurs du
grand débat il ya les maires favorables
absolument il ya les maires qui sont
totalement opposées qui veulent pas en
entendre parler
il ya les maires facilitateur qui met à
disposition des salles pour ceux qui
veulent organiser et les maires
organisateurs critiqué les maires
organisateurs convaincu vous je suis
pleinement convaincu évangélisateurs
c'est à dire que je veux voir mes
collègues pour leur dire c'est c'est
intéressant de s'inscrire dans cette
démarche pour leur dire il ya plus
d'opportunités pour vous en tant qu'élus
locaux pour votre population que de
coups à prendre on n'est pas dans des
réunions de quartier on est dans une
démarche globale leur dire aussi qu'à un
an des élections municipales
ce serait une faute peut-être de ne pas
écouter leurs concitoyens qu'on pourrait
leur reprocher après et donc essayer de
convaincre et avec sébastien le corps du
jeu fait un peu le tour des popotes pour
que les grands débats se multiplient
merci vincent chauvet on y reviendra
et puis notre troisième et dernier
invité c'est léo coûté là que vous êtes
enseignant chercheur bonjour les au
coutelas que vous êtes universitaire
vous êtes passionné par par ses fins par
la démocratie participative la
démocratie citoyenne
vous êtes inscrit dans cette démarche il
ya déjà 3 10 ans qu'est ce qui vous
plaît là dedans
ce qui me plaît c'est quand les
habitants les citoyens le finalement les
gens ordinaires reprennent la main par
eux-mêmes pour eux mêmes avec une visée
effectivement de changer leur existence
concrètement parce que je crois que ce
que le mouvement des gilet jaune à
montrer c'était cette envie là et c'est
la raison pour laquelle je suis très
sceptique par rapport aux grands débats
pour
vous n'êtes pas forcément grand débat
parce que ça vient de la base parce que
d'une part c'est une grande opération de
communication présidentielle
on le voit des banques les moyens de
l'état sont mis au service du sauvetage
d'un pouvoir qui est aux abois et ça le
mouvement des jeunes dans sa majorité
n'a pas été du pain alors voilà on voit
que les moyens de communication sont mis
pour essayer de contrer cette idée là
mais les réelles moi je le vois à la
base nous il ya très peu de gens qui
seront enthousiasmés par ce grand débat
mais quand même aller voir ce qui s'y
passe et vous moi j'y suis allé je suis
allé dans une réunion où on a voté à la
fin si ce qui avait été dit dans cette
réunion serait mis dans le cas du grand
débat ou pas j'ai trouvé la démarche
assez intéressante moi j'ai voté contre
je suis pas contre le fait que des mères
ou des conseillers départementaux ou
régionaux organisent des réunions
localement c'est ce qu'on demande depuis
tellement longtemps
ce que je remets en cause c'est la
structure globale et le rapport de force
politique dans lequel s'insèrent ce
grand débat l'impression que l'on a
c'est qu'on cherche à domestiquer cet
élan populaire de reprise en main
politique qui est née maintenant depuis
deux mois et c'est contre cette
domestication que l'on se bat et la
deuxième chose que je voudrais dire
c'est que un débat un grand débat une
des conditions démocratiques c'est qu'on
en connaisse l'issue ici on ne sait pas
du tout ce que ça va devenir quand est
ce que ça va donner
et comment vont essayer archives et les
propositions parce que les propositions
et centrait et terrorisant dit normand
validé par qui on a quand même
l'impression que c'est pour gagner du
temps et pour un petit peu ralentir la
mobilisation populaire en cours en
l'envahir revenir bien sûr sur les
modalités l'éventuelle référendum qui
pourrait être issue de ce grand départ
ou pas alors que s'est-il dit hambourg
bonn depuis le début de ce grand débat
vous propose quelques éléments et
moments captés par nos équipes
résumé par hélène lecomte et michel j lo
st désert 19 janvier stanislas guerrini
délégué général de la république en
marche je viens présenter ses voeux aux
élus de son parti
les gilet jaune profite de l'occasion
pour s'exprimer
et 457 niches fiscales y a rien sur le
pouvoir d'achat
y a rien sur les retraites pouvoir
d'achat justice fiscale retraite ces
sujets reviennent inlassablement ce jour
là si stanislas guérini discute avec les
jets les jaunes le député robert roth
lui refuse on est sur un aéropage
d'extrémistes qui essaye de se
déstabiliser la république
alors moi je veux bien recevoir des gens
dans des formes républicaine mais je ne
le ferais certainement pas sur le champ
de foire
les députés nous méprisent pourquoi on
est là aujourd'hui c'est pour ça c'est
pour ça même les députés
comment voulez-vous que un président
nous écoute si ses sbires ils nous
écoutent pas autre lieu autre contexte
cette fois ci le débat est prévue et
organisée à dijon une centaine de gilet
jaune exposé leurs doléances à quatre
parlementaires de la république en
marche
la réponse qui a été donnée sur le smig
c'est une prime c'est pas une
augmentation du smic pour trouver des
mesures et pour nourrir les pauvres gens
vous faites les fonds de tiroirs des
gens moyens l'aéroport de paris l'année
prochaine et puis quoi encore on va
privatiser la justice ça va privatiser
les hôpitaux
je ne comprends pas comment vous pouvez
vendre nos biens ce qui rapporte à coup
sûr sur le smic ou la privatisation des
biens publics la parole est clair
tranchante par comparaison celle des
élus peut sembler convenu didier martin
je crois qu'il est possible de faire
vivre et la démocratie représentative
est une expression directe de nos
citoyens démocratie représentative et
citoyenneté c'est le thème choisi par la
députée la république en marche perrine
goulet à saint loup dans la nièvre elle
a organisé ce débat auquel participent
80 personnes j'ai envie d'entendre pour
construire savoir ce que les gens
veulent pour la france de demain
parce que voilà il on est à mon avis un
tournant d'une société et il faut
l'entendre et voilà réfléchir ensemble
this de maumont veux je disais la
responsabilité de représenter deux mois
et demi après le début du soulèvement
des gilet jaune on est très loin des 80
km heure ou du prix de l'essence
il se passe effectivement quelque chose
d'important alors on l'entend bien avec
ce reportage
ce qui a mis le feu aux poudres au
départ c'était le prix du carburant la
baisse du pouvoir d'achat enfin le
sentiment car non les gens une partie de
la population se sent véritablement
prise à la gorge vincent chauvet est ce
que c'est aussi ce qui remonte chez vous
à houtain quand vous discutez avec vos
administrés absolument il ya des
questions sans ça dure aujourd'hui de
pouvoir d'achat indéniable il ya des
questions aussi de territoire qui se
sentent oubliés qui se sentent méprisés
un sentiment parfois plus qu'une réalité
qu'il est important d'exprimer pour moi
ce grand débat loin de domestiquer à un
mouvement populaire que ses deux
structures est ce qu'aujourd'hui
qui peut dire ce que veulent les gilets
jaunes il n'y a pas qu'à mener
thématiques qui remonte donc à moins que
les gilets jaunes ya d'autres citoyens
d'écran doit rien voit on voit dans
l'est dans les réunions et dans les
grands débats
beaucoup des personnes beaucoup plus
large que simplement ceux qui s'étaient
mobilisés mais il est important face à
sète
ce mouvement social d'ampleur de trouver
des revendications de faire remonter des
thématiques parce que les manifestations
pour les manifestations les blocages
pour les blocages ça n'amène rien et
pour que ce soit constructif en disant
que l'ex est important d'avoir des
débats les goûters l'ex tructures et et
vous comprenez le fait que l'on sait on
n'a pas vraiment de porte parole dans
dans ces mouvements c'est compliqué
d'avoir des interlocuteurs et de fédérer
un peu pour remonter les idées c'est ce
que vous dire que ce que ce mouvement
soit insaisissable
je le concède c'est sa force que ce
mouvement ne soit pas structuré et ne
soit pas en train de s'enraciner sur les
territoires ça c'est faux nous avons
créé nous récemment dans la vallée de
l'ouche un pas très loin de dijon une
assemblée populaire territoriale faisant
suite à l'appel qui a été lancé par des
groupes de commercy par le groupe de
commercy ça a été peu médiatisé mais il
y avait quand même 75 voire 100
délégations de ronds-points d'assemblées
locales de gilet jaune partout en france
qui ont débattu sur un week-end c'était
400 personnes pour précisément dire ce
mouvement il doit gagner en cohérence et
il doit se structurer par lui-même et
pour lui même et donc se créent
maintenant depuis plusieurs semaines des
assemblées populaires territoriales se
créer des maisons du peuple ça ressemble
à un grand débat mais créé par les
citoyens à quoi si vous voulez quand on
pose comme condition du grand débat que
deux les deux revendications majeures du
mouvement qu'il a fait émerger ne seront
pas discutés hurler de lire la une sur
la justice fiscale qui est là sur le
retour sur la suppression du sf sa non
on n'en parle pas sa puce la flat tax et
quand 25 milliards 40 % du budget de
l'enseignement supérieur et la recherche
je sais de quoi je parle et le deuxième
c'est le référendum d'initiative
citoyenne ça non plus on n'en parle pas
alors c'est vrai ou c'est drôle ça la
question de la justice fiscale et au
centre et il n'y a pas que celle
dispositif ôta dispositif où il en parle
il ya deux ans trois ans il y avait les
sms que le monde était plus beau est ce
qu'il y avait moins de sdf c'est vous
savez là c'est une mesure symbolique
peut-être mais en tout cas la question
de la justice fiscale est un vrai thème
du grand débat et la question du
référendum qui se disent at il partagé
populaire 17e' présidentielle est aussi
un vrai thème et à étang sur arroux
le président a également dit qu'il
croyait à l'expression démocratique
diack et au référendum
et moi je fais partie de ceux qui sont
convaincus et partisans de la
concrétisation de ces grands débats par
référendum à choix multiple au moment
des européennes
ça pourra vraiment permettre de entendre
et écouter les revendications des
citoyens et sur des vrais points et pas
seulement de se réunir sans programme
sans but précis mais de structurer le
débat politique qui rit falconnet
est ce que dans les débats que vous avez
vécu déjà du côté de chenôve dans
l'agglomération dijonnaise vous avez
entendu ces questions qui remonte et est
ce qu'on a le droit de les aborder dans
le grand débat bien sûr on a le droit d
de les aborder dans le grand débat le
grand débat national donne un cadre et
ensuite les citoyens sont libres la
parole est libre
moi je dirais il ya trois positions qui
qui se dégage vous avez des gens qui
viennent se défouler voilà exprimé leur
colère
voilà deux manières de manière impulsive
ils viennent dire au président de la
république au gouvernement aux élus qui
organise organisé dès la voilà on en a
marre on n'en peut plus on n'en peut
plus des des fans mois qui commence le
case voir des débuts de mois qui
n'existe pas pour nous parce que voilà
on est dans la dans l'extrême difficulté
on n'en peut plus effectivement de la
taxe carbone après nous avoir dit
achetez du diesel on n'en peut plus on
n'en peut plus notamment les classes
moyennes je pense que les les très
pauvres par exemple dans un quartier
politique de la ville comme à chenôve et
on n'a pas de gilet jaune
on en a quelques-uns mais dans les
quartiers dans les quartiers les plus
résidentiels sur le constat est tout le
monde va partager
quel que soit d'ailleurs le la position
où le bord politique tout le monde va
partager le constat et les difficultés
de ces gens là est ce que ces gens là
sont uniquement dans la démarche de
parler de leurs problèmes - est-ce
qu'ils apportent aussi des solutions
alors il ya une deuxième position qui
est celle de gens qui qui viennent en
ayant préparé les choses c'est à dire
sur les différents thèmes
fixée par le président de la république
et sur d'autres viennent avec des
propositions très concrètes
alors vous en avez d intéressante
justement qui vous rendent par exemple
la flat tax ça revient le rétablissement
lisf et c'est pas parce que je lovett
une mairie dirigée par un socialiste qui
est qui le disent mais comme mesure
emblématique de la justice fiscale et je
suis un petit peu en désaccord avec avec
mon collègue
je pense effectivement que la politique
c'est des actes concrets mais c'est
aussi de la symbolique
et puis je voudrais répondre à monsieur
ne tenait qu'à tallec sur la question de
ces assemblées populaires citoyennes et
de ses maisons du peuple et maison du
peuple à existe ça s'appelle les mairies
ça s'appelle les hôtels de ville et je
pense que ce que vous dites c'est
significatif de la disparition et du
mépris des corps intermédiaires par par
le gouvernement et par le président de
la république parce que les citoyens
aussi et ça c'est la troisième position
c'est de dire on vient on vient écouter
mais on n'y croit pas et ça c'est
terrible parce que ils font état de leur
balade de leur défiance complète
vis-à-vis de la politique alors pas
vis-à-vis des élus locaux
parce qu'ils le disent les élus locaux
sont là on les connaît ils vivent avec
nous ils savent ce que c'est que notre
vie il nous écoute parce qu'on est sur
le terrain on a aussi mis en place des
dispositifs de consultation de
participation citoyenne j'ai fait avec
mes collègues à chenôve on a fait plus
de 80 réunions permanences de quartier
visites de quartiers envahis les gens
nous en nous en remercient on va y venir
à la participation citoyenne mais
peut-être les eaux cotelec sur la mairie
maison du peuple et le rôle des élus de
proximité puis ensuite à saint jory qui
veut réagir également il est certain que
les élus de proximité un rôle à jouer
dans cette histoire et il est évident
que toute tentative de reprise en main
démocratique passe par une
réappropriation spatiale et temporelle
ça c'est évident la réappropriation
spatial ce mouvement l'a bien montré
il est dans la lignée du mouvement des
places il a été d'abord l'expression de
reprendre l'espace public par les ronds
points
tous les samedis
l'espace public la rue c'est parce qu'il
y à une quand même une sentiment de
désappropriation ou bien sûr qu'il
existe des mairies mais les citoyens ont
quand même l'impression que ces mairies
sont surtout des outils de gestion
parfois de bonne gestion parfois de
mauvaise gestion selon l'oms mais pas
des outils pour donner aux citoyens les
conditions d'une réappropriation
politique de leur existence concrète
quelle mairie a mis en place alors que
le code des collectivités territoriales
le permet des référendum d'initiative
locale autant voilà je me sais très bien
que non consultés c'est pas la même
chose
moi je je crois que là il ya justement
un quiproquo ou dit le référendum c'est
les citoyens qui décident d'essayer
hâtive locale moi c'est pas ce qui est
important c'est pas le riz coup le
référendum d'initiative locale ce qui
m'intéresse ce qui m'intéresse et des
conditions qui ce qu'on crée du débat
politique au préalable et ça il me
semble que les gens aujourd'hui se
sentent dépossédés des décisions qui les
concernent tous les jours donc c'est
cette reprise en main concrète par des
dispositifs concrets qui fera que demain
les gens en retirant le goût à la
décision retrouveront le goût à la
politique
on va reparler de démocratie locale dans
un instant vincent j'aurais voulu réagir
à ce que disait thierry falconnet et
certainement aussi excuse événement et
on voit qu'il ya un double effet à ce
grand débat d'une part l'effet
expression les gens s'exprimer ont des
choses à dire et les ont soit
spontanément sur les ont préparés mais
ont des choses à dire et le deuxième
c'est l'effet écoute ce qu'on a entendu
c'est effectivement que le gouvernement
peut-être le présent la république
peut-être n'était pas assez à l'écouté
et que là on est dans une phase d'écouté
quand on regarde les sondages sur ce que
veulent les citoyens par rapport à leurs
élus avant l'emploi avant
l'environnement avant la sécurité c'est
un être à l'écouté mais ça je pense que
ce grand débat c'est aussi une grande
écoute des français et puis pour ceux
qui se mobilisent pour ce vraiment qui
ont des idées des propositions d'autres
modes de gestion le mouvement des places
il a abouti à quoi en espagne au fait
que les indignés à dos ont pris par
exemple la mairie de barcelone se sont
présentés et ont géré une collectivité
communauté humaine avec un mode de
gestion peut être plus participative
peut-être moins rigoureux en régression
sociale mais en prenant le pouvoir en
organisant comme il voulait dans les
élections dans un an il ya des élections
municipales ce serait très bien que ceux
qui aujourd'hui sont en train de
s'organiser et bains propose ce qu'ils
veulent faire et mettre en place des
référendums le contrainte des mairies
alors dans le cadre de ce grand débat
france bleu a lancé une vaste
consultation sur son site internet
oui absolument c'est
évidemment la question des services de
proximité qui est au centre de cette
consultation de consultation ouverte sur
le site francebleu.com faire jouer alors
justement quels sont les premiers
enseignements de cette consultation
citoyenne
réponse tout de suite avec denis
souillard et bien vous êtes plus de 5000
à nous avoir écrit et l'organisation de
l'état et des services publics fait
évidemment partie de vos propositions
il ya d'abord toutes vos remarques qui
concerne la santé et le milieu
hospitalier et louise avance des
solutions pour lutter contre la
désertification médicale notamment des
dispensaires itinérant sur france bleu
point fr mars elle nous a écrit pour
multiplier les maisons de santé en
milieu rural muriel demande aussi
simplement plus de moyens pour le milieu
hospitalier les services publics de
proximité c'est aussi la mobilité pour
vous et géraldine propose plus de
transport collectif en milieu rural
bénédicte réclame plus de pistes
cyclables en milieu urbain et christophe
lui aimerait aussi être connectés et de
bandes le développement d'internet en
zone rurale alors on voit que parmi les
questions qui révèle que naît il ya la
question des services publics en général
on parlait de du rôle des mères de la
place des mairies ce sont aussi des
services publics en quelque sorte et
souvent elles supplay l'absence de
services publics par moments dans
certains points que ce soit d'ailleurs
les banlieues comme chez vous ou le
périurbain ou carrément le rural est ce
que ce sont des questions qui ressort et
lesquels des rides avant la question du
service public et du service public de
proximité et de qualité ressort ressort
des débats mais elle ressort de nos
préoccupations quotidiennes
j'ai entendu tout à l'heure les maires
sont d'abord des gestionnaires il nous
arrive aussi d'avoir des visions
politiques et d'avoir des programmes
politiques je rappelle d'ailleurs qu'il
ya quand même des élections est
régulièrement les citoyens sont appelés
à nous sanctionner ou validé
nos politiques nos politiques locales
donc la question la question de la santé
la question de la sécurité
la question de l'emploi quels grands
services pour accompagner les demandeurs
d'emploi dans une ville comme chez nous
quand vous avez sur un quartier
politique de la ville près 30 % de
chômeurs devrait prendre le demandeur
d'emploi la question de la sécurité de
la tranquillité publique avec quand même
des politiques de casse de la justice et
de la police c'est à dire la sécurité de
nos concitoyens avec là aussi les maires
qui se substitue à ces carences en
recrutant les policiers municipaux en
mettant en place d'aidés des politiques
de tranquillité publique
la question de la santé dans une ville
comme celle au avec de plus en plus de
poids des grands des grands secteurs
privés qui d'une certaine manière
prennent le domaine de la santé avec des
politiques gestionnaires et des
politiques d'actionnaires ça ce sont des
questions qui reviennent
effectivement et que nous vivons nous
les maires au quotidien alors assez
différente en place dans assez
différente dans l'autunois renaudies
janin absolument il ya toujours ce lien
au service public qui reste très fort
avec les français mais mais qui est
distendu cours avec le service public
mais plutôt que la défense d'un service
public ou de l'état ou des collectivités
locales les français
les habitants de l'autunois les
morvandiaux envie de vivre mieux et
d'assurer un avenir leur enfant on voit
par exemple que les thématiques qui
ressortent c'est peut-être un peu moins
l'emploi nous mais beaucoup plus le
recrutement les entrepreneurs qui dit
comment je vais faire pour recruter je
refuse des chantiers parce que je peux
pas recruter pour les jeunes qui se
forment
est-ce que l'agriculture a un avenir est
ce que le nucléaire a un avenir
est-ce que là où je veux créer mon
entreprise ou là je suis en train de me
former
on va continuer à avoir des usines ou
des activités dans ce domaine sur les 20
prochaines années
on est sur une question la question de
la thématique du monde rural qui qui
parfois se ne trouve pas trop sa place
et un peu écrasée par des métropoles à
des problèmes de transport quand on peut
plus acheter depuis le 1er janvier sa
navette à autun où paray le monial pour
la gare tgv parce que la région ne
permet plus des choses comme ça quand on
a des bts qui sont refusés décès ap qui
ferment on se sent
un peu méprisé et c'est ce genre de
thématique qui remonte et je pense que
c'est aussi aux autres échelons et au
niveau de la décentralisation qu'on peut
faire davantage de progrès pour redonner
du sens au milieu rural et au cou
thellec trois minutes d'émission je vous
le dis pour que vous sachiez qu'on
arrive bientôt des mais je trouve que là
on est typiquement dans les environs 8
et du grand débat évidemment qui
voudraient moins de services publics en
milieu rural qui voudraient moins
d'infirmières qui voudrait qu'il n'y ait
pas des agriculteurs qui s'installent
qui voudrait qu'il ait pas des
maternités plus localement etc
mais comment faire avaler c'est une
évidence mais le problème c'est l'argent
ce que les gens disent c'est une colère
contre un gouvernement qui défend un
système économique qui valent inverse de
sa serre que le grand débat c'est un
piège idéologique sterk on peut discuter
de ce qu'il ya à l'intérieur du verre
mais surtout on ne discute pas de la
façon dont le verre il est fabriqué on
ne discute nous disent qu'il faut
changer dans les institutions notre
façon dont il faut il faut remettre à
plat un pouvoir qui n'a pas de
légitimité qu'est ce que vous dites aux
gens qui vous dites ils font ce qu'ils
vous disent il faut baisser les impôts
mais on veut plus de service public ça
paraît pas antinomiques mais bien sûr
que non c'est pas antinomiques
c'est une question de ré c'est une
question de répartition des richesses
l'impôt sur le revenu il faut que ce
soit plus progressif les 5 milliards de
cadeaux qu'on a donnée aux riches avec
un flat tax et la suppression de l'usf
sur les dividendes
cet argent là vous croyez pas qu'il peut
servir pour des postes d'infirmières
vous pouvez pas qui peut servir pour des
contrats aidés dans les associations
parce qu'on parle des services publics
mais le roc des associations localement
à qui on a réformé le contrat aidé ou en
tout cas qu'on l'a rendu tellement
difficile que cette année il ya à peine
un quart des demandes de contrats aidés
qui sont faites ça c'est du concret doc
c'est une question de répartition des
richesses en changer de volonté de
changer le cadre ou pas vincent chauvet
c'est une
répartition des richesses léo coutellec
vous abondé dans son sens moi je
comprends qu'ils s'inscrivent pas dans
le grand débat parce qu'il veut changer
radicalement de modèle de société il
veut détruire la société dans laquelle
on est il n'accepte pas le modèle
républicain d'un gouvernent peut-être
innocent nouveau type de ceux ci 207
détruire s'il est un peu fort quand même
assez en tout cas en tout cas le grand
débat ne remettra pas en cause les
provinces intérêts publics non plus la
démocratie française pour aller vers des
types sixième mandat public mais vous ne
connaissez pas romero anglaise
démocratie bollinger plus la ville est
le groupe présent dans le public a été
élu il sera présent la république
jusqu'en 2022 au moins et donc c'est à
lens 1 ça ne permet pas et donc non il
est présent mais intérêts est plus
orienté après les autres à la vème
république et si les situations si les
données la démocratie si référendum il
ya il ne doit pas être un référendum à
choix multiples comme s'est proposé sur
des petites mesurettes vous voulez de
réaction de quelque chose de structures
merci mais vous pouvez les émissions
maintenant vous remercie d'avoir accepté
de répondre à ces questions merci thomas
merci de nous avoir suivi et à très
bientôt sur france bleu et france 3
[Musique]